[Music]
little mix faces off against their male
doppelgangers for a
fierce dance battle that's amazing
and no your eyes don't deceive you
those doppelgangers are perry leanne and
jade themselves
on friday little mix dropped their music
video for their single confetti
featuring
the video shows the trio perry edwards
jade
thurwal and leanne pinnock dressed to
the max in a nightclub
as they face off against well themselves
[Music]
yeah that's perry jade and leanne
hitting the dance floor for a showdown
with their alter egos
pez j-dog and lenny
are going so well and i just wake up
every day and i thank my lucky stars i
have these three girls
[Applause]
the ladies rock beards braids and thick
chains
stand at a urinal together and make
small talk about the gals while little
mix gossips on the other side about the
guys
juno is doing it for me who lenny
yeah hitting different isn't it yeah
i think i've got a chance for perry now
you think yeah
also i'm sure he's wearing a wig
see jade she yes she would
get it yeah to be fair you all would
the music video which is really a short
film also features cameos from three
drag race uk stars
bimini bomb boulash tace and
ahora who shut the men down after they
get a bit too rowdy
the cheek the nerve the goal the
gumption the audacity
get out get out go on
hold on a minute girls don't worry about
this one
i've got it and on friday perry offered
fans a behind-the-scenes look at her
transformation on instagram captioning
this shot quote behind every great woman
there is a great man that is a woman in
prosthetics
i think the message here is well i'll
just let my all-time favorite little mix
song do the talking here
[Music]